you've probably heard by now that he
gave me my own show and if you haven't
heard now you've heard welcome to your
new life I promise I won't keep getting
this close physically I will continue to
get closer emotionally having a show is
so exciting but what's even more
exciting is that the show finally has a
name so get ready because the grace
Helbig show is coming to eat on Friday
April 3rd at 10:30 p.m. following the
soup and you are going to love it I also
make a lot of promises I keep only a few
of them this isn't your normal talk show
we're shooting in a house with real room
and a real kitchen and really high rent
thank you II is gonna be celebrities
friends family comedians they're all
gonna come by and they're all gonna hang
out with me some against their will
we're going to have tons of fun tons of
fun
so tell everyone you know shout it from
the mountaintops
excu for having a mountain in your yard
the grace Helbig show is coming to
Fridays at 10:30 p.m. on E starting
Friday April 3rd following the soup
Friday April 3rd that's very soon I
should tell my mom no she's smart so
figure it out and Jackie I'll tell her
after she posts it to everyone on
Facebook checking those Facebook
I'm just kidding on Jackie I love you
except you really do love Facebook well
it's not a bad thing watch your shows
during Friday April 3rd 10:30 I'm
following a soup seriously I'm just
kidding